it's uh never easy to guess what he will
play because as you say he plays
everything we have a quick guess guys
before he makes the first move
i think it's going to be one of these
annoying moves i think he'll try to not
play into the main lines and so we might
see something
like this is this is the the key move
yeah against magnus age 10. yeah this is
the move that beats
the mouse slip variation he tried to
play the english he slipped and he's
played c3 is it an annoying opening move
it's not an amazing first move because
it doesn't really increase your options
as white now we're transposing into
pretty much a queen's pawn opening but
white hasn't gone for the most direct uh
kind of most ambitious attempts white
hasn't really seen space why it hasn't
really developed any pieces but as simon
mentioned this is a bit of a secret
nugget of information if you want to
beat magnus h10 on the app
one c3 simon used it simon actually
mouse slipped but beeping up and then i
used it to win as well so yeah
record maybe magnus has been watching
your game yeah trying to beat himself at
age 10
[Laughter]
i don't even know what an app is i'm not
and i guess they're not using the apps
in prison either half an apple that's
the old-fashioned way with no more than
the books yeah the board and the books
you can't beat books
i love books i think david wants
i was watching one show and you said
something like you know if you've got
books and you write it down people can't
hack into your books yeah and that's
actually a golden nugget of information
you write your own notes and things i
mean i like that idea we must keep books
and they smell nice and they smell nice
and they look good in your house
exactly
there's so many chess players i know
again i think i mentioned this but you
go around their house and they've got a
hundred books but i haven't really
opened any of them yeah it makes them
look clever
okay well we should do a quick uh
like survey around the table so how many
chess books do you guys
have i've got loads obviously have you
read
like would you say you've read more than
50 of them
will tell you
i keep on making more room for mine and
she said where have all my books gone
and i say well mine are reference books
yours are novels
mine are important but academia there it
is for your work but of course people
who don't play chess get confused
because they look at the library and
they say this book says how to win with
the sicilian big thick book and then
this book says how to beat the sicilian
which one do you read i mean it's
ridiculous
this is black i can get frustrating
absolutely well you like ask me how many
how the percent percentage on my books
chess books
it's a hundred but i only have
i only have two chess books you've got a
couple more now yeah
yeah i need two yeah that's true yeah
that's true but these are these are
exactly the kind of chess books that i
read that's a reference book of course
that one but somebody did say a great
thing i mean
i know i joke about getting older but
you assess things think i don't need all
these books and i've gone through many
times that i'll get rid of loads i can't
get rid of them i can't choose which
ones they've got sentimental value but
you really if you really thought about
it do you need more than 10 chest books
ever
and the other
thing i would say is is there one book i
still can't after decades think if i was
on a desert island what one chess book
could it take that goes this is chess
this is everything i need in one book it
doesn't exist
surely it doesn't exist
yet
this is it there it is
no yeah
no i'm always trying to slim line my
chest collection and like here i have
problems but i i've kind of become a
little bit more comfortable with the
idea of giving away if i can give them
away to chess clubs and they
say kind of i've kind of promised to
give away a lot of my chess books to
bergen's chess class which is a local
chess club yeah but the problem is it's
like i haven't been there i apologize
i'm sorry it's been cool go there let's
think of it yeah
and actually if there is one book
that describes the whole of chess of
course simon it is chess and fishing
best book you can get it's very rare
though apparently i mean you'll struggle
to find it but if you do find it yeah
you'll join me we have one of the only
copies in the world
simon did uh tease us and he uh invented
a book called chess and fishing and we
all believed it written by well wow
two two of us believed it one of us was
going hang on a second
and afterwards i texted him and i was
like simon
would you what do you mean the chess and
fishing by
van winkle
[Laughter]
the knight's stable yeah we got the
knight stable in there
and is this a stable position we do see
the knight moving david it's very stable
and both players have spent a bit of
time so
um we have seen a very strange first
move from magnus pawn to c3 on move one
it's a rare opening i don't even know
the name of it to be honest but we have
transposed into a variation of the
trompovsky attack
you could argue maybe it's a tory
kind of system as well
there's a couple of names for this type
of position and okay the position is
becoming a bit more normal we did see a
trader pawns in the center now uh sam is
going to push the pawn in front of the
black king one square
i assume and we'll see the play take
maybe a slower
uh slower course this pawn structure is
called the carlsbad structure and it
arises from the queen's gambit the karo
khan um openings like this one as well
so they will be using pattern
recognition to understand where the
pieces belong
um maybe which pieces to trade off and
there we go sam does push up on forward
opening up the black dart squad bishop
we've seen magnus win a lot of positions
like this when he played the london
system he won a famous game against the
polish by way check
um where he normally does a combination
of two things he tries to win the light
square bishop with a knight to the edge
and he also tries to hit black's b pawn
with a queen move maybe we can show well
dave is pointing out those moves there
and both of these moves are a little bit
annoying uh for black because uh he he
has to sort of somehow defend so it's
these little strategies when you play an
opening you need to know uh what you're
trying to achieve and i expect that
knight will want to come to the edge if
he gets a chance yeah so he's pushed his
bishop forward one square and as you
mentioned simon this is kind of the the
kind of sister variation of the london
system which would be a direct
transposition if white's bishop was back
here it would be the
london system direct
directly but uh yeah next move if for
example black does the same and develops
i think we'll see your move in action
the white knight going to the edge of
the board trying to capture this bishop
and at the very least you've imbalanced
it slightly by gaining the bishop at
night for bishop
trade so i wouldn't be surprised if sam
in the current position maybe tries to
find a way out of that maybe he'll push
his pawn forward asking a question of
this bishop so that if the bishop
retreats then at least his own piece has
an escape square but uh yeah some
calculation to be done maybe if this
pawn does indeed step forward attacking
this bishop will see a trade and then
the other idea you mentioned the white
queen coming over to attack this
undefended pawn so magnus he's got a lot
of experience in this type of position
maybe not this exact position
and it's up to sam um what is he going
to do here where is he going to put his
bishop which side is he going to castle
the black king you could make an
argument for okay he does play that move
the most natural move in the position
and
yeah black's king can choose which flank
to castle on
later in the game so okay the bishop has
been kicked away and the bishop's
stepping back now an escape square and
black's pieces very harmonious ivanka
you must have had this type of position
in the karu khan as well very similar
to structures there many many times
i have to say though it does feel like
this is a nicer position than i would
normally get in the karakan
for black because uh the light square
bishop is comfortably out it's a great
diagonal dark square bishop is also on a
great diagonal as well
um
and the reason i kind of highlight those
two pieces is that the dark squared
bishop controls uh the e5 square which
is a square that the whites usually use
as a springboard to start a kingside
attack yeah normally white tonight wants
to whoops sorry me and my aris the white
knight wants to jump into this squad
and normally this is uh
yeah this is a beautiful square for the
white knight but it's not possible right
now
and we also mentioned keith arkell um
the endgame expert he loves these types
of positions for black because he's
going to try and enact something we call
the minority attack the black rook
coming across and these two pawns
actually running forward to undermine
these three white pawns so if black gets
the chance he's going to push forward
and create the minority attack trying to
weaken white structure on this flank at
least create a target for later on in
the game so watch out for that one
maybe sam will play this move already
bring the rook across
lots of choice and very comfortable for
shankland already mm-hmm but he spent uh
quite a lot of time i guess we're only
in move 11 we still have almost all of
the pieces on the board yeah and he is
uh thinking a lot yeah we talked about
openings in general and
end games being the more fun part right
magnus just wants to take this into the
middle game the end game he doesn't care
about going for an opening advantage
with white and okay starting the
minority attack potentially black's rook
getting ready to throw
the black pawns down the board and
magnus
very typical carlson esque move stops
that idea and magnus of course he also
has chesable courses he has two i think
one is on
the strategy of the world champion the
way he thinks and one is on the end game
so i guess that is the chessable course
for you as well then carl indeed yeah
and i'm reminded also a prisoner wrote
to me saying why he liked pawns so much
he said because in the prison yard or in
the school playground when the big guy
the knights or the bishops or the rooks
have a go at the little guy the little
guy usually loses but in chess when the
little guy attacks the big guy the big
guy has to move and the little guy wins
we like that i like it that is true but
talking about little guys i mean i was
just shocked actually by the decision
that sam shanklin just took you know
picking up gary and moving it two
squares and just
whoa leaving some squares open
for his king uh that's the black king
really airy really really shaky and
that's very very committal and now catch
up because there have been a few moves
lots of trades here knights coming off
the board bishop's coming off the board
and maybe with the exchanges black's
king is less of a target because white
doesn't have any attacking ammunition
anymore but okay the white knight
stepping back hitting the black bishop
and black's bishop is just going to
retreat
you mentioned you were shocked by this
ivanka but the black king pretty safe
for now it is pretty safe for now but i
just think it's such a committal
decision
it wasn't necessary it wasn't necessary
if you ask me i mean
you know you could have played
other
plans and uh waited with this this idea
until personally i quite like it i must
say because you've gotten rid of two of
white's main pieces you mentioned
occupying this square for example for
white one of the main goals that's not
really going to happen anytime soon
if we just see i mean maybe we'll see a
trade of bishops at some point white
might try to exchange off black's only
defender but um i don't really see how
white is going to build an attack white
only really plays on the king side in
this position white never really touches
pawns on this left side of the board
because he only leaves weaknesses behind
that black can use on a semi-open file
so if white is restricted to one side of
the board it makes it kind of makes some
sense to exchange pieces
and yeah i mean i think black is super
flexible black can even break in the
center at some point
i'm not saying black's better but uh i
think he has no real problems here
yeah i don't like it
i like my i like my safe keys
contradictions ivanka you love pushing
pawns i know i know i know i'm very
fickle you know it's someone else's uh
someone else's positions and i just
don't i don't know i i
would have felt a little bit more
comfortable with my making not being so
airy and magnus actually pushing forward
with alice the a pawn to the fifth row
and this is actually a plan that i've
seen in very recent
years and maybe in 2020 it became very
very popular to take as much space as
possible on this wing and white's idea
is to just you know
push push put a knight on the c5 square
and then you know just carry on taking
space it's a very magnus position isn't
it i mean you talk about kind of
position that magnus plays better than
anyone in the history of chess it's this
kind of position where yep maybe it's
even maybe maybe it's even i do actually
still like white a little bit because i
think his plans may be a little bit
easier to play but it should be even but
magnus just knows all the right plans
and here he goes he starts to maneuver
around um but sam's playing very
ambitiously with his pawn move so it
shows at least he's going going for some
activity as well uh where's that knight
going i mean i would i would have i
would have moved that knight the other
way and try to bring it to the center
like d3
so i i'm i'm thinking okay is it heading
towards the right hand side david
possibly looks weird to me that move but
is the idea to perhaps just trade off
bishops
if i thought if he goes to be free it
has a better route tonight maybe maybe
we could show that like either there or
even back to c1 and i want to try to
bring it to the center so i'm surprised
that the white knight went that way yeah
yeah this is actually the dream square
for example just giving white a few
moves here um this structure the
carlsbad structure as they call it um
you can actually search that i think as
well on chesapeal where you have two
pawns they act as a perfect shield for
the white knight the white knight is
flexible to jump towards the black pawns
on this flank or to jump towards the
center so as simon mentions that
traditionally is the ideal square for
the white knight so it is slightly
surprising to see magnus go the other
way
and from this square it actually takes
four moves to get back to the ideal d3
post so um he's not going in that
direction definitely and uh maybe that
means he's going
okay no magnus continuing to play on
both flanks he's kind of keeping us
guessing keeping his opponent guessing
maybe the white knight is going towards
this side to start annoying the black
king but first magnus
kind of begins by undermining this black
pawn i don't think you want to trade
pawns here because it only opens up the
white rook and also you're left with
this one isolated pawn the downside is
if you bypass white's pawn then any end
game now is going to be very dangerous
for black this pawn is only two squares
away from promotion
if you can imagine white's knight i know
it's on the other side of the board
right now but if the white knight picked
itself up and plonked itself here maybe
in an end game going after black's pawn
then it would be really dangerous i've
seen magnus win countless end games once
his pawn gets this far forward so yeah
magnus teasing us
teasing his opponent may be going for
the black king maybe going for something
on the queen side as well um we will see
for sam
he needs to find an active plan black's
pieces are nicely centralized but what
to do next
that's the big question yeah will magnus
even go for an attack i mean uh i i'm
looking at moving the f pawn at the
right moment
it looks i don't know it looks a little
bit odd but you know when you have
weakened your king as black has done you
should always try to look at the targets
over there and see how you can open up
the position so if i was white i'd be
looking at trying to use a lever levers
we've seen it before we saw prague
use the lever against magnus when he
used the g pawn and maybe we can just
highlight that pawn at some point
potentially coming forwards i mean it
looks a long way off but maybe we could
uh go f4
and try this move um you need to prepare
it but maybe this pawn forward or harry
the h.4 just to undermine this uh
stronghold for black i was actually
going to ask you about this move um as
you know this kind of gives an
opportunity to trade off a bishop for
the night what do you think
i don't think i would personally i don't
think he'll ever really take it he's
hitting at it and i think more it's more
that this is an outpost for his pieces
and it's an annoying outpost he wants to
destabilize black's pieces along this
diagonal he's also stopping sam doing
anything because the one pawn break sam
has is that e pawn in the center of the
board
he's basically magnus has ruled out this
this push now because then you can take
the knight off the board and you just
win a pawn so maybe magnus's idea stop
black's play build up slowly okay sam's
trying to build that move up again there
of his last move but if you can stop
your opponent's counter play well it's
half half of the way to winning
yeah and uh this pin is annoying but for
now black can deal with it for example
if the white queen comes out try and add
pressure on this diagonal blackstroke
will just come back and guard the black
knight and the reason i say i don't
think any trades will happen here is
because okay even if the queen's come
off suddenly white knight is just on a
terrible square dominated by the black
bishop black bishop controls a lot of
squares right now
so i think magnus just wants to use his
pieces to annoy black more than anything
in the current position i wouldn't be
surprised if he brings his queen out to
one side and then starts to maybe bring
this rook to the center maybe by lifting
his rook up and doubling up on this file
um or maybe just centralizing his rook
first of all
in case black does try and break at the
wrong moment
you have really tense really strategic
middle game and uh chances for both
sides but
he knows who's better who knows who will
kind of navigate this type of position
i mean you could you could you could go
for this night check and move the h pawn
if you want to go completely sort of
randomly attack with just your knight
and porn so it doesn't look like it
should work but uh i mean there is
there's some weird ideas like that
floating about as well so yeah i i you
know it wasn't it was really interesting
watching magnus play his position
because i wouldn't have expected white
magnus to put his knight over here
so what's his plan i'm kind of still a
bit like well i don't know maybe that
knight should be in the center but
we'll see i mean if it was anyone other
than magnus i would maybe be slightly
critical that he's being inconsistent
kind of playing on one side brought his
knight to the king side and then kind of
playing on the other flank
um yeah i mean it all depends on the
next few moves maybe he's got a big
master plan up his sleeve that we've
struggled to see yet maybe you're right
simon maybe he'll suddenly launch some
attack against the black king but
it doesn't feel like the black king is
too it seems very solid right now yeah
it's very hard to attack it with just
the knight but you know we you could you
can maybe again try to stretch black a
little bit your idea david of doubling
rooks
seems very sensible as well uh i i think
here but lots of noise and still prefer
white i think ivanka would you take
white here or i i like white um i just
think this is a magnus type of positions
and
you're also talking about pawn breaks
i'm also very tempted to
not just soften up the pawns on the
right side but also maybe try to have it
all and
maybe even at the right time prepare a
pawn break in the middle of the board
and uh we can see on the camera that sam
isn't actually that happy either he's
shaking his head
yeah that's the thing if some kind of
could control his emotions a bit more i
think he would maybe even already be top
20 i mean top 10 in the world maybe
he's been a phenomenal player for so
long now
um just one established uh 27
plus player but i think he could go even
further just sometimes it's the moments
like that whenever i've played him
sometimes i just notice he's not happy
and that just gives me a confidence
boost and i've played against that a few
times to beat him even and uh do you
think psychology is very very important
then because you're mentioning there
it's helped you beat sam in the past
there and that's psychology really
realizing your opponent's weak
giving yourself energy i mean i i think
it's a really underrated thing in chess
in general not many books are written
about psychology at the end it's a mind
sport right so yeah it must be important
i know it's something he's worked on
he's much better much more stable kind
of uh
much more kind of focused now than he
used to be um i mean one of his coaches
jacob arghard
um yeah they i mean one of the greatest
chess authors out there chess coaches
and if that's something they've worked
on the psychology but yeah it's it can
always be improved right nobody's
perfect
nobody's uh
completely oblivious to all external
factors
meanwhile you're shaking
sorry nobody's perfect you live and you
learn it it's a song by
hillary duff or something
oh wait it's miley cyrus
it's hannah montana yeah
yeah
that's my favorite tv show i'm surprised
you don't know
all right well calm game so far
but do waiting for it to maybe explode
open a little bit it will at some point
yeah just not quite yet magnus needs to
stumble across a plan well aneesh giri
he is uh finished for today a uh jewel
and one point for him against the
shakira and mamdiara also within one
point for mamdaro so it is a very uh
solid and good start to the tournament
for anish giri he has won now
three games the other one straw he is no
one has been able to beat unish giri
and he is safe inside top eight so far
with two days to go in the preliminaries
the opening expert
yeah and talking about mama jaroff
actually i would love to see a
chessboard course
from him especially on his creative
openings you know the way he just pushes
gary the g pawn two squares with a
carefree abandon does that move three
yes always against the queen's gun but
declined he somehow he always finds a
way to attack against one of the most
solid openings in chess yeah yeah it's
incredible just like an attacking manual
from him you know that would be uh
incredible to to see how his brain
thinks talking about chess spectacles
that you were saying i would love to
get into the mind of these great
creative attackers well every time i
look at the game if i tune in and it's
two-thirds of the way through the game
these pawns just sort of come down the
board and you say how did they how did
they even arrive there
exactly
time after time it's like space invaders
exactly
maybe you will be uh surprised because
actually we haven't been able to follow
any we have only seen slightly uh some
of momyaro's games but actually he has
only played he lost one game to mishra
and he won one game to shanklin ollie on
one draws
a little bit surprising he usually has a
lot of decided results
maybe not typical of him no
no but we did actually see in the oslo
esports cup you know that when push
comes to shove he can play in a really
positional way i mean we saw him
do what's
become basically an endgame grinder in
the style of david and he did that to
jordan and it was very impressive and he
won the final match to magnus carlsen as
well yeah played magnus in an end game
that's
not
i mean not seen every day very few
people outplay magnus in the end game
yeah
and this one will this go to an end game
will the queens come off i think so
possibly i think this is good chances
for
an end game i'm just struggling to
understand firstly what sam is shaking
his head about so much over the last few
years but also what magnus has been
thinking about for nearly seven minutes
now
i don't see him too much to calculate i
understand he's trying to kind of
decide upon a plan but
seven minutes in this position could it
be something like uh push hari i mean
are they thinking about making some kind
of committal move going on the attack
he's going for it i mean i i thought he
could check and push harry definitely
with a knight but maybe he's aiming for
something similar with this move like
the f pawn or the h-pawn trying to try
and do something along those lines yeah
yeah so
magnus after over seven minutes wow
brought his queen to this square and uh
simon says maybe pushing this pawn
forward maybe pushing this pawn forward
uh kind of keeping his options open but
he's also trying to provoke sam forward
so sam now it's very tempting to push
this pawn to hit the white queen but the
white queen might even step back um i
mean the whole way anywhere safe and
even if black starts pushing white i
think is happy to have seen uh yes
white's lost a lot of time but white is
happy to have seen this pawn push
forward because now at some point i know
black can try and attack i know this is
a bit scary but if black is just a bit
too slow and just waits for example then
after a trade of minor pieces white has
a new outpost in the middle of the board
white has control over this beautiful
dark square
also going towards the white king uh the
black king sorry
so i think pushing this pawn at the
moment
is maybe a bit too risky for black
because you lose control over the e5
square something we touched upon earlier
um
pause don't go backwards but harry the
eighth pawn does move forwards yeah this
is very interesting move i mean sam is
certainly
playing very aggressively and and it
sets up a bit of a trap here right if uh
if white now takes that pawn i guess i
mean
uh complicated it's complicated still
but can you take the pawn the whole idea
is that if white grabs this pawn after
some trades suddenly the white queen is
hit and the black queen he's going for
it
magnus must have calculated this in
advance it looks like black is about to
win if the white queen steps back the
black queen dives into the position and
takes this pawn protected by her rook
now
but it's just one check the white king
can actually run away and suddenly the
rest of black's position is a bit loose
this pawn under fire suddenly remember
this pin the black queen's been
deflected away from her own knight
very risky
very risky way for him i mean this is
kind of on on magnus like to change it
so so so in such a big fashion when he
didn't need to the position and give his
opponent i mean black has some kind of
attack here surely surely yeah surely
yeah surely you know even at the worst
case scenario the queen can kind of do a
hit and run take the pawn dash back
and uh well what's key he's not going to
feel safe on the f1 square i mean what
if you try to just come forward to the
queen and then with the rook to attack
the queen i mean just try to play in the
most aggressive way you can okay let's
jump back in
so queen takes pawn is a check it looks
like this is bound to be played what
else can some do uh i think he's gonna
play this check you might as well grab a
pawn for free and yes you have to deal
with this pin ivanka mentioned the black
queen can just go back
park herself back where she came from
defending this knight defending this
pawn but uh simon mentioned maybe the
more ambitious option attacking the
white queen and
we're about to see this maybe um this is
the current position on the board before
this rook move where does the white
queen go i'm trying to work it out maybe
it goes to g3 here maybe this is the
problem
um possibly so i quite like quite like
ivanka's idea just bringing it back
consolidating and because you've got
then that push in the center later
you're keeping a lot of love ideas alive
so yeah dropping the queen back maybe
pushing one of these pawns later still
with this idea in mind also with the
idea of bringing the rook the whole way
down with a nasty check hitting the
white king and can you go a bit alpha
zero like as well go with the king one
square forward to the sixth row and then
uh start the chasing yeah for example
stepping forward with the black king and
then pushing for pawns forward to hit
the white queen lots and lots of ideas
and actually we have this on the board
um i was just going to show one
variation which i think is very maybe
natural or maybe very tempting for lower
rated players which would be to hit the
white queen it looks aggressive and
after this you think oh i can give a
check hitting the white king oh i can
give another check so many checks but
once the checks dry up once the white
king runs away you realize oh even after
a rook trade too much is hanging the
black queen in the corner isn't under
attack and the black knight under attack
so you can't just get carried away and
only look for checks looking for checks
is good first but if they don't work you
have to backtrack and that's why uh sam
retreated his queen to a safe square and
now magnus just stepping forward with
the pawn he's getting ready to create a
safe haven for the white king
still very tense
um i don't like this transition for
black at all i must say but uh
okay neither side's king is entirely
safe yet okay and the clock is really
ticking fast for sam shanklin he is now
under five minutes on the clock queens
are on the board rooks are on the board
is this difficult to play with
the clock ticking yep
especially while the kings are open
i mean those are the positions where we
see all the blunders right
um
what do you think here the knight
against the bishop that's the main
imbalance bishop controls the knight for
now i'm really liking the bishop
actually the more i'm looking at this
i'm thinking yeah i thought magnus's
idea was a bit too risky but then i'm
thinking genius as i normally do when i
watch magnus's games it's like why are
you doing that magnus you're like yeah
that's why you're the world champ right
because
because that bishop is so phenomenal
even if it drops back two squares what a
lovely diagonal that light square bishop
will be on i mean we can maybe just
highlight the square it could come to um
at some point and okay well sam is
pushing forwards
really risky moving
i mean
it looks very loose doesn't it it looks
incredibly loose i mean the first move
that comes to mind is this okay bishop
takes knight okay he doesn't play bishop
takes knight i guess sam's idea is that
maybe he wants to sneak in with the
queen this way or maybe after pawn takes
pawn he wants to sneak down with his
rook and unleash a nasty discovered
check against the white king magnus is
having none of that he says okay no fun
for you um maybe it was good for white
anyway but in the current position he
just tucks his king away to safety
and uh yeah i was going to say earlier
it's the art of doing nothing for magnus
he kind of provoked sam into this whole
harry the h pawn push just five six
moves ago magnus spent seven minutes and
then he just kind of did nothing sam is
the one pushing here uh but is he
worsening his position that's the
question yeah sam gains space yeah i
mean it looks really impressive with
those pawns but what color square are
they on they're on the light squares
what does white have light square bishop
those paws are going to be weak in the
ending definitely if he gets to the
ending as well because at the moment i
mean it looks like uh certainly white's
king is a lot safer
you said the art doing nothing that
sounds like some self-help book taoism
or something taoism or something like
that uh winnie the pooh they aren't
doing nothing i'm sure
i'm sure there's a book like that so
yeah but that'd be a good name for of
course isn't there that i'm doing
nothing i'm shorter-ish yeah i'm sure is
i hate these self-help books myself
i love them
yeah he's doing something though magnus
he's trying to break open the center
ivanka mentioned these two black pawns
and now he's undermining the magnus so
if for example the black pawn continues
to push forward now it's simon's other
idea maybe the white bishop stepping
back look at this diagonal juicy the
white queen is going to sneak in to
check this would everyone's self-help
book be titled then so um if you if you
if you're going to write a self-help
book
what would it be called so that's a good
question we need some help from twitter
and maybe from the audience kyle i might
have to come to you soon on this one but
you might i think mine will be called
how to say no oh
are you good at that or not it's a small
word but very difficult to do
people get in the most extraordinary
trouble because they can't say no that's
so true there's my self-help book that's
actually a good one i like that very
good answer yeah i've actually read that
book called
honestly it's actually a book called i
thought i'd just be really clever i
thought that was definitely come on no i
don't know how to say no i've never seen
it i know yeah okay
and there is enough basically you just
say thank you for the invitation
yeah thank you for the invitation and uh
you kind of say no not this time so you
give them well if you're having a meal
with somebody and you really don't like
what you're eating and they say would
you like some more oh it's very nice
well you just get more of the same yeah
just say no and say i'm a little bit
full up you know but it was a lovely
delicious meal i'll maybe have it next
time i'll just say i'm not very fond of
your cookery
no you won't get invited back oh and
look at the bar in this one oh no for
sam shanklin yeah i was trying to say it
was a critical moment and this pawn push
we mentioned it's so risky for black
black has abandoned the light squares
completely
and i think that's going to come back to
haunt him
in the current position
okay magnus goes for the open file
i'm slightly surprised i mean there were
two options that i mentioned uh well the
first one i mentioned dropping the
bishop back trying to sneak in with the
white queen along this diagonal um the
second option that i was very tempted by
was actually pushing this pawn forward
trying to break through on this square i
wasn't exactly sure how black was
actually going to defend this pawn
utilizing a pin uh utilizing the white
queen here but instead magnus goes for
another
probably quite strong option he's hoping
to break through on this line and it
looks like this pawn is very far
advanced forward but if you try to push
it then i think it just gets rounded up
for example the white rook is just going
to come and goblin uh gobble up this
pawn in conjunction with the white
bishop
yeah it's uh it's hard to see a move
actually here for black you never ever
want to okay he's brought his king
forward this allows the bishop to
retreat with a check yeah i mean what
surely one wants to play that anyway
yeah yeah why is it why is he why is he
done that i don't understand what bishop
just comes back and gains a move the
black king has to retreat but that's a
hot but i mean this only helps white i
was thinking that was a good move for
white anyway so uh i i mean the queen
can step in and it's game over isn't it
i mean the queen if it steps in maybe
the black knight can hop back and defend
oh even if we're defending here but i
mean
comes
[Applause]
keep an eye on sam's face when when
magnus checks that king but i mean it
it's
it's a really weird move to play just
because there's a light square bishop i
don't understand it i think sam panicked
he's low on the clock one thing about
sam is in long chess he's great
classical chess because uh he has time
to think and i saw a post by him on
twitter just last week talking about how
he's worked so hard for years on rapper
chess and he still can't master it
because he panics when he gets low on
the clock and this is a panicky move um
king on a light square ready to get
checked giving your opponent time for
free to improve their position
yeah i mean do you have any tips for
okay and here comes the bishop with the
check and uh well black is gonna be so
vulnerable on the light squares running
this way but still on a light square
i mean the queen can still march forward
uh okay first magnus trades a set of
rooks he's going for the cynical
approach i think he just wants to bring
his own rook across and pick up this
black pawn this pawn is an intruder but
it's walked into no man's land it's got
no support
and it might well just drop off if black
tries to defend it with his rook this
allows some nasty queen checks
if black tries to defend it with his
queen then maybe now the white queen
sneaks in yeah and the black queen the
black knight cannot kind of
gallop over to the defense of its king
it's looking bad for shankland
a bad day for sam he uh lost to mama
jerome he lost to jordan fun for east he
did win against mishra but uh
probably i guess then a loss coming up
here against magnus
yeah i mean it's just the momentum is
all in white's favor the clock's in
white's favor
it's easy for white to find moves and
he's shaking his head sam shanklin and
uh clock's ticking down to
one minute
yeah magnus magic i mean he got nothing
at all out of the opening but queen
chief was so clever and loving it was
psychologically you know
it was the kind of killer move because
it just provokes
to come forward yeah and this is like
look at sam's pawns now i mean every
move that sam went forward with has
become a weakness the pawn in front of
the rook the pawn opening up the the
light squares you're right ivanka it's
just
really clever you know he had that long
think and he just found this
amazing idea actually after doing
nothing
magnus's key move did nothing but he
provoked sam into worsening his position
but it was almost like he understood
sam's weaknesses
and he went and played on that skill i
was thinking about this mood you know
desperately trying to swap of queens but
i was thinking actually white doesn't
even have to do that white can throw in
be a little bit fancy throwing a bishop
check
and uh then once the king moves you can
step backwards with the bishop and to
defend her queen the king could not take
that white bishop and the king has to
protect the black queen and yeah how's
your vanco mentions you can trade queens
here and then win this black pawn the
intruder in white's camp or you can keep
the queens on yeah and looking at that
bishop it's quite incredible from my
point of view it's been it started at f1
b5 then to d3 now g6 the trouble that
that bishop has caused when many people
might have just swapped it off for the
night
without a second thought and now look at
it it's tremendous
here we are again another bishop move
that bishop's done all the heavy lifting
in this year yeah it's tremendous
kicking away the black queen and next
move that black pawn drops with check
aha yeah the white rook just picks it
off now and
you have an attack and you have an extra
pawn yeah and you have the better pieces
there's maybe one danger right in the
position you know
black's pieces don't look like they're
well placed but you know if he's a bit
careless then maybe they can line up on
the h line that's a little bit of a pipe
dream at the minute but you never know
to be a good defender i always feel you
have to be a good optimist well you have
to be an optimist basically i i would
never play this last movie either i mean
take a pawn with check and attack or
just move the pawn i mean
he's having fun he's enjoying himself
bit too much here i feel magnus says
yeah and the the king is trying to
scuttle away but
like david said you're a pawn up with
the attack um so promise that's black
king no matter where you put it it's not
going to feel entirely safe
i mean now that black king even though
it's made its journey over to the queen
side suddenly remember that white pawn
that white that magnus pushed all the
way up to the sixth rank what was it 20
moves ago suddenly that white pawn might
help an attack against the black king
and okay the black knight has blocked
this check
white's rook can now just go and take a
pawn
um yeah there we go the black queen if
it takes the white bishop then the black
knight will fall
two pawns and the attack now not just
one point it's two pawns in the attack
and
i mean uh
you have to try it wow i mean it's not
gonna work whatever you try it
there's one important tactic is if black
rook actually comes down to the fifth
rank to attack white's queen then white
can actually use his rook and go and
capture the black knight there's some
tricks there but white is going to win a
piece and
all the tactics work in your favor
it's no coincidence it's because you're
on the attack it's because you have the
better pieces white species are
coordinated protecting each other all
pointing in the same direction black's
pieces are just scattered
and here we go bishop for night trade
and magnus now remember that white pawn
i said it that white a6 pawn it helps
the attack
after all of that seeds looks like he's
resigning here yeah it is uh over sam
shanklin loses to world champion magnus
carlsen so magnus finishing off the day